à quelques semaines de l'arrivée des
premiers touristes d'été une
constatation s'impose l'île de france ne
dispose pas d'équipements suffisants
dans le domaine du camping et du
caravaning actuellement il n'y a dans
notre région que onze terrains de
camping qui ne dispose au total que de
8000 places
fredrik astou a essayé d'en savoir un
peu plus en consultant le comité
régional du tourisme
et puis on se rendront aussi dans l'un
de ses terrains de camping celui de
melun en seine-et-marne à 40 km des
portes de paris au bord de la rive
gauche de la seine le terrain de camping
de melun la rochette dispose de près de
200 emplacements destinés à accueillir
des tentes de campeurs et des caravanes
créé par le syndicat intercommunal de
melun et de la commune voisine de la
rochette
il a ouvert ses portes en juin 1995 en
dehors de la période d'été ce camping
héberge essentiellement quelques
familles de travailleurs caravane et et
de jouer à septembre il accueille en
priorité les touristes étrangers de
passage qui font une halte de quelques
jours près de paris sur la route de
leurs vacances
le passage ce sont des gens du nord
des hollandais des anglais des allemands
qui font une courte étape d'une journée
ou deux jours nous avons aussi des gens
du midi italiens espagnols suisses qui
viennent passer une semaine pour visiter
paris
c'est d'autant plus facile que nous
sommes à 20 minutes de la gare de lyon
est que nous avons des trains le matin
et soir une trêve ni c'est très bien
organisé pour pour ces gens là qui
rentrent le soir qui retrouvent leurs
caravanes
qui évite des frais d'hôtel mais le
camping la belle étoile de melun la
rochette n'est pas le seul terrain de ce
type c'est à dire disposant d'au moins
200 emplacements de tentes et de
caravanes de la région parisienne
malheureusement on en compte
actuellement que 11 de cette dimension
sur l'ensemble de l'île de france dont
les plus fréquentées sont celui du bois
de boulogne à paris et celui de
champigny sur marne
de plus la quasi totalité de ses onze
terrains de camping se trouve dans
seulement deux des huit départements de
la région
la seine-et-marne et les yvelines ce qui
ne suffit pas héberger les nombreux
touristes étrangers de passage dans la
région parisienne durant les vacances
d'été estiment les responsables du
comité régional du tourisme et des
loisirs un organisme issu du conseil
régional d'ile-de-france il le france
souffre d'une grande faiblesse en
hébergement touristes de toute nature
mais particulièrement dans le domaine
des villages de tentes et des
emplacements pour caravanes
nous n'avons même pas en ile de france 2
% de la capacité d'hébergement de toute
la france et c'est pourquoi le comité
régional de tourisme et le conseil
régional ont décidé aussi quelques
années une politique bed d'appui terrain
il faut faire un tel effort parce que la
demande est considérable le comité
régional du tourisme participe chaque
année à cinq ou six salons
manifestations à l'étranger et je peux
vous dire qu'au temps à bruxelles à
utrecht à berlin par exemple nous avons
des demandes très très importante de
gens désireux de venir passer huit jours
quinze jours même en région parisienne
avec leurs caravanes et que nous ne
pourrons pas accueillir faute de place
pour développer le caravaning et le
camping en ile de france
les responsables du comité régional du
tourisme ont décidé de participer au
financement du futur terrain de
choisy-le-roi au sud de paris
actuellement en cours d'aménagement sur
plus de 9 hectares à côté de l'auberge
de jeunesse d'un coût évalué à plus de 4
millions de francs il devrait accueillir
les premiers des 500 campeurs attendus à
partir du mois de juin
à plus long terme le comité régional du
tourisme envisage de faire aménager un
terrain de caravaning de plusieurs
hectares près de torcy à proximité de
marne la vallée en base de plein air de
nombreux touristes pourraient ainsi
s'arrêter quelques jours en elle
france mais les responsables du comité
régional du tourisme ne veulent pas en
rester là
selon eux le développement les terrains
de camping et de caravaning devrait
inciter d'autres touristes à séjourner
plus longtemps dans notre région celle
ci ne serait plus alors une simple zone
de passage sur la route des vacances
d'été